today on the Matt wall show much has
been said about the rise of hate and
bigotry in America but most of the
people lamenting this alleged phenomenon
are themselves huge proponents of
bigotry and racism so long as it's
anti-white racism we have some egregious
examples for you today also leftist
justices on the Supreme Court embarrass
themselves during oral arguments over a
freedom of religion case a former
Twitter moderator talks about the trauma
his job caused him I reveal the hidden
Brilliance behind Time magazine's
Entertainer of the Year and king and
queen victim Harry and Megan get ready
to release their new docu-series because
all they want is privacy we'll talk
about all that and more today on the
Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know using the internet without
expressvpn it's like taking a phone call
on speaker in public you don't know
who's around to listen in on your
private conversation and when you go
online at a VPN internet service
providers they can see everyone every
single website you visit and what's more
they can legally sell that information
to ad companies and Tech Giants without
your consent that's why I use expressvpn
expressvpn hides my online activity from
internet service providers my identity
is anonymized and my data is encrypted
for maximum protection that sounds
complicated I assure you it really isn't
all I have to do is fire up the app
click one button it's as simple as that
then I'm free to roam the internet
without any prying eyes expressvpn works
on all devices including phones laptops
and routers so that everyone who shares
your Wi-Fi can be protected so secure
your online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com Walsh today that's exp r
e s s vpn.com Walsh to get an extra
three months free of expressvpn that's
expressvpn.com
well during all the recent controversies
surrounding Kanye West and his
statements we have heard quite a lot
about the dangers of demonizing and
scapegoating entire groups of people
we've heard condemnations of hate and of
hateful language we've heard that
there's a rising tide of hate and
Prejudice and that it's getting worse by
the day especially now that Elon Musk
has taken over Twitter allegedly that's
made it all worse and and it's true of
course that we shouldn't demonize groups
that part is true I agree with the
people who warn against such bigotries
the problem is that many of those people
do not agree with themselves and if they
are wondering why their anti-hate
sermons their homilies of love and
togetherness tend to fall on deaf ears
as the alleged hate tide continues to
rise despite their protest they may want
to take a long look in the mirror the
fact is that the very system now thrown
into hysteria about the dangers of
fanatical racism has itself fanatically
promoted racism for many years and
continues to do so today now
you can call this what about ISM I don't
really care I am unapologetically saying
what about what about is a perfectly
valid argument that needs to be brought
up very often
um so what about the openly genocidal
racism that the corporate media
Hollywood Academia the left generally
pushes without apology and without shame
every single day what about it are we
ever going to talk about it are any of
the eager denouncers ever going to get
around to denouncing that
well I know the answer but I asked the
question anyway rhetorically last night
thanks to a repost from Christopher a
video went viral of a Rutgers Professor
named Brittany Cooper speaking at an
online conference conference hosted by a
popular website called the root now this
video is actually from a year ago went
viral back then
but and I may have even mentioned on the
show back then but the ensuing outrage
almost entirely coming from
conservatives on social media amounted
to absolutely nothing Cooper was not
fired was not suspended was not
denounced or even lightly reprimanded
nothing
she's still teaching college students
today this in spite of the fact that she
was on camera preaching the most
virulent form of anti-white racism
imaginable
just watch
I think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here now you know
I've heard people sort of say it is
one I think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that why people don't know
right what they have done they know they
fear that there is no other way to be
human but the way in which they are
human which is so you know like you talk
to white people and whenever you you
really want to have a reckoning about it
they say stuff like you know it's just
human nature if y'all had all of this
power you would have done the same thing
right and it's like no that's what white
humans did white human beings thought
there's a world here and we own it prior
to them black and brown people have been
sailing across oceans interacting with
each other for centuries without total
subjugation domination and colonialism I
have seen uh what a what a show this
iteration of
treatment of other human beings means
and that my hope is that we would do it
differently you know in the moments when
we have some power
white people are committed to being
villains she says now put any other
group in that sentence and she loses her
job
black people are committed to being
villains Asian people are committed to
being villains gay people are committed
to being villains Jews are committed to
being villains
literally any other group at all in that
sentence and it becomes the sort of
statement that her career cannot survive
and we haven't even heard the worst of
it yet not even close
perhaps more troubling giving her her
profession is the hallucinatory
hallucinatory version of world history
that Brittany Cooper who refers to
herself by the way as Professor crunk
offers up and we haven't heard the worst
of that yet either she says that black
and brown people were selling sailing
around the world and interacting with
each other without Wars of Conquest
without subjugation without colonization
there's nothing to say about that claim
except that it is totally absurdly
ridiculously false there is not a shred
of truth to it whichever groups qualify
as black or brown especially those
groups that lived in North America or
Africa what we know for certain is that
they were slaughtering and enslaving
each other without Mercy since time
immemorial European Empires did not
invent the idea of subjugating a foreign
land and turning it into a vassal state
and they didn't even practice the most
brutal form of the practice
this was utterly commonplace across the
entire Globe for millennia so professor
professor crunk is either so dumb as to
qualify as medically brain damaged or
she's a hateful lying propagandist or
perhaps some combination of both and
that's what I suspect
she continues by offering her solution
to the white problem her final solution
we might say listen
that's the thing that white people don't
trust us to do because they are so
corrupt you know their thinking is so
morally and spiritually bankrupt about
power that they can't let you know they
fear viscerally existentially letting go
of power because they cannot imagine
that there is another way to be it is
either that you dominate or you are
dominated and isn't it sad that that is
spiritually who they are and that they
can't imagine a sort of more expansive
notion of the world the thing I want to
say to you is we got to take these
mothers out but I know but like we can't
say that right we can't say like I don't
believe in a project of violence I truly
don't because I think in the end that
our souls suffer from that the world
didn't start when white people arrived
in America and tried to tell all the
rest of us how things were going to go
there were people out here making worlds
Africans and Indigenous people being
brilliant and you know libraries and
inventions and you know vibrant Notions
of humanity and cross-cultural exchange
long before white people showed up being
raggedy and violent and terrible and
trying to take everything from everybody
so we hear again Her Fantasy Land
alternate retelling of world history
adding in the detail that Africans
somehow made it to North America before
Europeans she then imagines that
indigenous people had libraries which
would be difficult considering that most
of the tribes didn't even have a written
language much less did they have books
and she says that they lived peacefully
until raggedy white people introduced
violence to the Western Hemisphere and
and she's right you know North America
was entirely free of violence before
first contact with Europeans
free of violence if you don't count
scalping cannibalism Human Sacrifice
rape pillage murder War slavery Conquest
Etc other than all of that
it was quite peaceful really not that
Professor crunk is an advocate of Peace
she says herself that she really wants
to take these mother efforts out
that they are corrupt and she wants to
take these mother efforts out again just
imagine black people are so corrupt we
need to take these mother efforts out
gay people are so corrupt we need to
take these mother efforts out Jews are
so corrupt we need to take these mother
efforts out
any of those statements and you are done
forever you're never getting another job
you're getting D platform from
everything uh you're losing your bank
accounts you are losing everything
unless you put white people in there
the only reason she stopped short of
fully promoting such a strategy is that
she can't say that she says and besides
she's worried that Exterminating white
people might be injurious to The Souls
of their exterminators and she's right
about that second part but not the first
in fact she can say that she wants to
murder all white people she did say it
and she suffered no consequence whatever
for doing so
later in the video she speaks wistfully
and hopefully about the coming end of
whiteness and assures herself and the
audience that
you know eventually white people will be
extinct and non-white people can get
back to living in peace without the
quote inconvenience of their presence
it is again in summary a genocidally
hateful and racist diatribe she is
calling for or at the very least
fantasizing openly about the
extermination of entire race of people
and she presented this to a media
publication on video and suffered no
consequence for it you can in fact in
this country openly call for the
extermination of white people without
the slightest worry that any legal
professional or reputational damage will
result
just ask Nick Cannon
he is currently as he has been for
several years the host of The Masked
Singer on Fox he's had high paying
high-profile jobs on national TV for the
better part of this century
and yet infamously he has openly called
white people Savages and postulated that
their lack of quote melanin makes them
sub-human
let's just take a trip down memory lane
and watch this again from a couple of
years ago and uh and here's what Nick
Cannon said
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it Soul we soul brothers and sisters
that's the melon in that connection so
the people that don't have it have are
are a lit and I'm gonna say this
carefully
are a little less and and and where the
term actually comes from because I'm
bringing it all the way back around okay
to Minister Farrakhan to where they may
not have the Compassion or the the when
they were sent to the mountains of
caucuses when they when they didn't have
the power of the Sun that was that the
sun then started to deteriorate them so
then they're acting out of fear they're
acting out of low self-esteem they're
acting out of a deficiency so therefore
the only way that they can act is evil
the only way they can they have to Rob
still rape kill and fight the flight or
in order to survive exactly so then
these people who didn't have what we had
and when I say we I speak of the
melanated people right they had to be
Savages they had to be barbaric they had
because they're in these Nordic
Mountains they're in these rough uh
torrential and environment so they
they're acting as animals right so
they're the ones that are actually
closer to animals they're the ones that
are actually the true Savages
acting as animals says the guy that has
like 10 kids with six different women or
something
um after that podcast interview Nick
Cannon did for a short period lose his
job which he quickly regained and has
gotten back to his TV career without any
issue but the momentary slap on the
wrist only came because during the same
podcast he said that black people are
quote the true Hebrews
which is an incoherent talking point
we've also heard from Kanye West also
not nearly as vicious or hateful as what
he said about white people generally so
Canon was chastised for the true Hebrew
Hebrews comment uh he even brought
briefly lost his job for it but there
was never any chastisement never any
denouncement from any notable person or
Organization for literally calling all
white people sub-human animalistic
Savages
because that's the kind of thing you're
allowed to say
not just allowed to say but rewarded for
saying
anti-white bigotry is not simply
tolerated it is celebrated Professor
Kronk and Nick Cannon aren't living in a
vacuum these these viciously anti-white
sentiments can be heard from celebrities
from college professors from government
officials and many others
the sentiments are expressed out loud
enacted into law they are set as policy
embedded into the system the bind
Administration gave out covid relief
according to a racial hierarchy with
whites at the bottom where I suppose
these Savage animalistic villains belong
as far as interracial violence go you
know because we hear that uh well all
these it's all the hate leading to
violence well okay let's talk about that
twice as many white people fall victim
to interracial homicide as committed and
that's just homicides we haven't even
you know we we've seen many videos of
groups of people in One race stomping
the hell out of an individual of another
race but the victim in those videos is
almost always white we have rarely if
ever seen it go the other way
certainly not recently
what this tells us is that anti-white
racism is permissible in our culture it
is the only totally permissible bigotry
that remains because and because it is
permissible it is also dangerous
it is the most dangerous
you know there there are other kinds of
bigotry that exist
but
if Society generally condemns a form of
bigotry
then the danger that bigotry can pose is
very much mitigated
because it is condemned by almost
everyone and certainly by almost all the
most powerful people
somehow it goes with anti-white racism
and and and nobody who speaks out
Against Racism bigotry and and yet
neglects to specifically denounce
anti-white racism
should be taken seriously
that's what this comes down to
if you're wondering why nobody can take
you seriously
it's because you see what we just played
there
and you either don't care
or you applaud
and that's why
now let's get to our five headlines
the hard year in the economy means that
essential practical gifts will be in
high demand this year give the most
essential gift of all America's best
meat and seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family when you give a mix a box of good
ranchers you're giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with 100 American
USDA prime and uppercut choices cuts of
beef Chicken and Seafood other meat
delivery companies and even your local
grocery store what they're going to do
is they're going to import lower Quality
Meat from overseas don't give your
friends and family less than America's
best this year not sure what to order
well good ranchers now offers gift cards
so you can let your friends and family
members choose for themselves or you can
give the gift of a subscription and
inflation proof someone's meat budget
for them go to goodrancers.com use code
Walsh at checkout to get 35 off your
gift that's goodrancers.com code Walsh
for 35 off good ranchers American Meat
delivered
as we mentioned yesterday the Supreme
Court is hearing arguments in a
religious liberty case challenging
Colorado's so-called anti-discrimination
laws which require Christian business
owners to participate in gay weddings uh
the challenge is being brought by a
Christian web designer who doesn't want
to be forced to design a website to
advertise or facilitate a gay wedding um
and the oral arguments were pretty
interesting so I want you to we'll play
a couple Clips here I want you to listen
first to cantanji brown Jackson
and she she manages to rope the film
It's a Wonderful Life into some kind of
strange hypothetical
which is meant to prove that Christian
business owners
shouldn't have religious liberty and and
uh it's you know it's it's hard to
connect these dots but she tries it
let's listen
Harley did the exact same analysis to
say is the parade organizers otherwise
but I really was a private Association
it wasn't a public business what I'm
asking you is I have a public business
I'm a photographer my belief is that you
know uh I'm doing It's a Wonderful Life
scenes that's what I'm offering okay I
want to do video depictions If It's a
Wonderful Life and
um I knowing that movie very well I want
to be authentic and so only white
children and families can be uh uh
customers for that particular product
everybody else can I'll give to
everybody else I'll sell them anything
they want just not the It's a Wonderful
Life depictions
um I'm expressing something right for
your purposes at that speech what about
uh what's the other step it's speech and
I can say anti-discrimination laws can't
make me sell the It's a Wonderful Life
package to uh non-white individuals
in the same way I would say first of all
in the same way that this court when
there is a message and a status and is
overlapping
the court would say that message wins in
that instance so I don't think so I
don't have to sell it to it I don't
think that that message is in that
hypothetical
okay uh we'll talk more about that in a
second so one of the people want to play
but uh so she's imagining here a
scenario where a photographer is doing
some holiday photos and has different
packages available uh which you know as
photographers do and uh but this
photographer
has has the It's a Wonderful Life
package but you have to be white so
maybe there's a black family that says
oh you gets a Wonderful Life uh photos
we'd like to take some sorry uh you got
to be white for those it's only for
white people can I interest you with the
uh in the Black Panther package that's
uh that would be more suitable for you
this this is the immense the situation
she's imagining because right that's
that's going to happen somewhere
um and she also talks about
this this site this this concept of a
public business
I I don't even know what that means it's
we're talking about a private business
we mean public business
they've invented like this category it's
a public business well it's public in
the sense that the business exists in
the public
okay so what she's postulating is that
is it what would qualify as a private
business
if a web designer
it's it's she she has her business and
as far as I know it's just her running
so it's like a a one-woman show web
designer and if that doesn't qualify as
a private business then what the hell
does is it a business that is not open
to anyone in the public
so it's a business but you won't sell
anything to anyone or provide any
services to anyone it's that sort of
business
just because you are a business that
offers a good or service doesn't make
you public it's still a private business
because it is run by a private
individual
um anyway we'll talk more about that but
there's another hypothetical she offers
and uh she has another sort of
interesting business proposal uh let's
listen to this
she is implicitly saying you know by
selling this I'm going to be uh
violating my own beliefs
um so let me just ask you another quick
hypo so I'm trying to understand the
extent to which this matters that she's
a speaker as opposed to a restaurant so
I sell food in one line of products that
I make is from scratch for particular
customers that are based on my
grandmother's cherished Family Recipes
my dearly departed grandmother was clear
that she only wanted to provide this
kind of nourishment for people who share
our same religious Heritage so I call
these products Grandma Helen's
Protestant provisions and I sit with
each customer who comes in and I hear
about their faith and their family and I
customize the recipe for them after
having this discussion so the food is
not expressive right I'm not speaking in
my food but I am trying to convey that
only certain people get to partake in
this product can I do that consistent
with the First Amendment or not no and
and in the situation as you said the in
terms of a caterer the caterer is not
engaging in speech okay so there's
there's the business proposal right
there so we've heard enough of that uh I
I kind of like that business idea you
know I'm fine with it so you got a
restaurant you know a chef and offers
different a different menu items
depending on your religion so these are
the Protestant Provisions if you're
sitting down the waiter goes up to you
asks you about your faith
and if you reveal yourself to be
Protestant then you get access to the
whole menu if you're Catholic then uh
they like will give you a an unleavened
wafer they say well this is what you're
allowed to have because you're Catholic
uh and if you're if you're atheist they
uh invite you to the back in in the
kitchen and they they have a they burn
you at the stake actually back in the
kitchen
um they're not gonna serve you then it's
like not gonna burn you and then serve
obviously they burn you at the stake and
then they would uh you know maybe bury
you in the back or something so that's
that's the the business idea that she's
because that's totally realistic right
that would definitely happen in reality
this is the reason why I like these
hypotheticals and there are many others
like this there are other hypotheticals
that container Brown Jackson offered uh
we've seen this in cable news when
they're coming up with all these well if
we allow this then what if this other
thing happens
it shows how desperate they are to come
up with some kind of SLI some sort of
plausible
slippery slope scenario
they are desperate to come up with
something and they can't do it
they've had many shots at this thing and
they can't come up with any actually
plausible slippery slope scenario for we
start with giving basic religious
freedom to private business owners we
give basic religious freedom to a woman
who designs websites and then next thing
you know
total chaos ensues they're not able to
bridge that Gap they can't explain it
and so they end up with all these
hypotheticals of things that would never
ever really happen
and it is very possible also
to separate the religious liberty cases
from all of these others
because there's a crucial distinction we
talked about it yesterday
and and in my mind the crucial
distinction is not even that it's based
on religious conviction that's got
nothing to do with it
The crucial distinction is that in all
of the all the the real life cases
whether it's the ones that have ended up
in front of the Supreme Court or other
ones that haven't made it to the Supreme
Court
in all of the real life cases
they are centered around gay weddings
and it is about is about private
business owners
it's about government entities trying to
force private business owners to
participate in an event
that they object to
that's the difference it's a very clear
distinction
so it is easy to delineate between a web
designer doesn't want to doesn't want to
make she doesn't want to be a
participant in this event and making a
website for the event is to participate
in it to some extent just want to do
that it's easy to distinguish between
that and someone who says oh we're not
gonna We're Not Gonna
serve you any food at all because of
your religious
convictions
or you can't get these these photographs
taken because you're black
okay you know if someone is sitting down
in your restaurant and they're just
trying to have lunch
that's not you part and you serve them
food that's not you participating in
some kind of formal event unless you
want to call lunch itself a formal event
um
the photographer taking pictures of a
black family that's not them
participating in some kind of event
however if if the black family or white
doesn't matter the race of the family if
a family said to them we want you to
come to this actual event that we're
putting on we want you to take
photographs at this event and of course
the photographer should have every right
to say well what is the event I'm not
just gonna like I want to know about the
event and if it's an event that I object
to
whether you agree with my objections or
not obviously you don't because you're
the one throwing the event if I object
to the that I'm not gonna I don't want
to be a part of it
and it wouldn't just there are actual
plausible scenarios so the left they're
trying to come up with their slippery
slope and it's completely ridiculous
they have all these things that would
never happen
the slippery Supple on the other end is
is actually plausible
so if we say
that uh the cake baker or the
photographer or the web designer doesn't
have the right to say no to the gay
wedding
what happens next what's the slippery
slope there
well you don't even need a slippery
slope because we've we've already
extinguished religious liberty so that's
that's not even a slope we don't have to
project about when that will have we've
already done it
well we can see where it will go next
for example
like we talked about yesterday divorce
parties are a real thing that actually
happen and people and people have
invitations for them they make cakes for
them they have they have photographs
taken
should you be required to go and partake
in a divorce party because you own a
business
what if it's some what if you're uh a a
liberal business owner and some one of
these alleged far-right extremist groups
comes along and says hey we're having a
big celebration we we need you to come
take pictures we need you to bake a cake
should you be required to be a part of
it
I mean what if it's uh
speaking of far-right extremists you
know pro-lifers far right dangerous
extremists that's what we are we're far
right dangerous extremists well what if
you're a pro a pro-abortion uh
Baker and and uh Roe v Wade was just
overturned
and I and I come to you and I say I need
you to make a cake customized cake and
it needs to say on it
um uh
hooray for the end of abortion or the
hooray for the end of of Roe
should I be able to compel you to make
that cake
if you say I don't believe in that I
don't want to I don't want to make that
you know there's a million other Bakers
out there go to one of them nope you
have to do it you are forced to do it
get back their slave and make it
so very very easy to to distinguish
between these two
but you shouldn't even need to because
as I said before it's it's uh
you know the the real answer and this is
not the answer the Supreme Court's gonna
is going to arrive at but the the
correct answer is is actually kind of
the absolute position that
you should be able to deny service to
anyone for whatever reason you want
and that should be it freedom of
Association you know you shouldn't be
required as a private business owner to
provide a good service to anyone
whatever your reason is for not wanting
to
and if you have truly awful bigoted
reasons if you do hang up the sign that
says no blacks allowed no one is going
to do that no business would actually do
that but if there was one in the whole
country that did they would be out of
business in 30 minutes because of it
all right
so the White House has responded to
questions about the Twitter files that
were released showing that the um
Biden campaign and other political
operatives had information about Hunter
Biden's laptops suppressed on Twitter at
the behest at their behest rather so
Karen Jean pair says that uh well she
says this was inappropriate and she
issued a formal apology from the White
House just kidding of course this is
what she actually said
is it the White House view that these
decisions were made appropriately in
light of what has come out
which Decisions by whom by Twitter my
Twitter on okay so look
we see this as a an interesting or a
coincidence if I may that uh that he
would so haphazardly uh Twitter was so
haphazardly pushed this distraction uh
that is a that is a full of old news if
you think about it
um and at the same time Twitter is
facing very real and very serious
questions about the rising volume of
anger hate and anti-Semitism on their
platform and how they're letting it
happen and you know the president said
last week more leaders need to speak out
and reject this and it's a very alarming
and very dangerous
old news she says it's old news the it's
old news that we rigged the election by
suppressing relevant information and
lying about it
her defense is that yeah it happened but
it was you know it's old news we already
knew about that it's ancient history a
couple years ago
and what is this Rising hate claim we
hear it again
Rising hate
well as we talked about in the opening
there is rising hate in this country but
it's not the kind of hate she's talking
about it's not the hate that she would
acknowledge
how do you measure hate on Twitter
because they're specifically telling us
that there's more hate there's more hate
on Twitter than there was before musk
took over
how do you measure that what is the
what's the uh what what units of
measurement do we use to measure hate on
a social media platform
how exactly would do that
well there's if you if you measure on
Twitter now there's uh there are 89 hate
units uh whereas before there was a 32.
when was the utopian time of no hate or
low hate on Twitter what was that
exactly
Give me the give me the years when that
was the case we can go back and and uh
scroll through some some tweets to see
if that's actually true
speaking of Twitter I also want to play
this for you uh maybe you've seen some
of these clips uh Joel Roth is a former
Twitter official former head of the
trust and Safety Division
and he was at a conference
recently about uh conversations on
Democracy in the digital age where he
talks about the justification talks
about many things
um one of those things is the
justification for Banning Trump from
social media
and it all has to do with the trauma
that he and other members of of the
Twitter staff suffered let's listen to
that
Donald Trump
that one I don't think was a mistake
January 6th so it it starts on the sixth
but it also starts prior to that that's
correct in the weeks leading up in the
weeks between election day and January
6th
Twitter moderated
hundreds I think the the final number
ended up as like 140 separate tweets
from just at realdonaldtrump that
violated various policies yes he was
good at that Integrity policy every
morning it was a new tweet much of it
was recirculating some of the same
narratives and all of it was focused on
the ultimately false claim that the 2020
election had been stolen and so we're
going into the events of the sixth and
there's that context there's the
centrality of his account and so you let
him get away with it for a long time in
other words well we'd been enforcing on
it right so we restricted the tweets we
put warnings on them you couldn't like
them you couldn't retweet them
um but we didn't ban him because it was
a relevant part of a moment in American
politics right
the events of the sixth happen and
um if you talk to content moderators who
worked on January 6 myself included the
word that nearly everybody uses is
trauma we we experience those events not
some of us as Americans but not just as
Americans or as Citizens but as people
working on sort of how to prevent harm
on the internet we saw the clearest
possible example of what it looked like
for things to move from online to off we
saw what was we saw the way that
rhetoric about a stolen election was
being mobilized on sites like the
donald.win sure we saw the trafficking
of this content terrible uh very very
tragic story there so forget about you
know forget about young men storming the
beaches of Normandy on D-Day
um that's not you know that that's not
the kind of trauma we're talking about
in modern in the modern world
people that are suffering trauma are
those who were content moderators on
January 6th that's the story our
grandparents told stories of World War
II uh but for Our Generation we will be
telling our grandchildren stories of um
you know moderating content on January
6th
traumatized
no you're not traumatized first of all
you have no trauma you're just a huge
fragile overgrown baby that's what you
are you are an emotionally manipulative
child
you know how to define trauma
just for the record what is trauma well
here's how because I looked it up
here's how the American Psychological
Association defines it not that I see
them as much of an authority on most
things these days but here's what they
say if you're curious trauma is an
emotional response to a terrible event
like an accident rape or natural
disaster
immediately after the event shock and
denial are typical longer term reactions
include unpredictable emotions
flashbacks strained relationships and
physical symptoms like headaches or
nausea
now you notice first of all that trauma
is associated with events that you were
a part of
so you had a terrible accident you were
raped uh you were involved in a natural
disaster that's where the trauma comes
from now we have people talking about
being traumatized by things that they
were nowhere in the vicinity of
and are you having flashbacks now
because of news reports about January
6th are you experiencing headaches and
nausea two years out still today
because some people trespassed in the
capital
while you were thousands of miles away
in San Francisco
is that so really
and besides how was your personal trauma
a even if you were traumatized which you
weren't how is that a reason to
de-platform someone your own personal
trauma is means that you can be platform
something
uh he also
talked a little bit about Babylon B and
how they ended up being de-platformed
let's hear some of that
okay Babylon B which is what got him to
buy the thing I think that's the that's
right the one which is which was not
particularly funny The Babylon bees man
of the year is Rachel Levine not funny
yeah
um and and you can I didn't agree they
should have taken that down but go ahead
you know it's interesting uh it's
interesting thing about what the
competing tensions around that are and I
want to start by acknowledging that um
the targeting and the victimization of
the trans community on Twitter is very
real very life-threatening and
extraordinarily serious
um we have seen from a number of Twitter
accounts including Libs of tick tock
notably that there are orchestrated
campaigns that particularly are singling
out a group that is already particularly
vulnerable within society and so yeah
not only is it not funny but it is
dangerous and it does contribute to an
environment that makes people unsafe in
the world so let's start from a premise
that it's [ __ ] up
but then again let's let's look at what
Twitter's written policies are Twitter's
written policies prohibit misgendering
full stop and the Babylon beat in the
name of satire misgendered Admiral
Rachel Levine
Twitter
nominally but it's still misgendering
okay and you know you can there can be a
very long and academic discussion of of
satire and sort of the lines there
interestingly uh Apple try to tease out
this question of satire and political
commentary in their own guidelines which
I think are are also fraught but you
know we landed on the side of enforcing
our rules as written and that's how it
got bought by Elon Musk just in case
you're interested he was mad about that
I remember that yeah we will never be a
thriving Society or civilization as long
as people like that are running things
and as it stands right now that is that
people like that are running things
these uh emotionally fragile
utterly narcissistic
um
the cry bullies
and and also do any of them strike you
to either one of the people on the stage
do they strike you as uh
experts on comedy it's not funny that's
not funny at all
if you have an idea for a joke or you
know run it by those two
and of course it's also not true now so
what it's it's being confirmed here and
there are many other cultures to play
them all you've probably seen enough
it's being confirmed what we already
knew which is that this was that they
were moderating they were moderating
things uh intensely ideological their
moderation policies and also based on
emotion based on the emotional whims of
whoever happens to be
um
in charge of moderating
so that's that's what's being that's
what's being confirmed there we should
also say for the record that this
nonsense well it's a life-threatening
the trans people are targeted by by on
Twitter it's threatening their lives
you gotta explain that to me exactly how
is your life threatened by a tweet
now your life could be threatened by
actual death threats
but the thing about the trans community
on Twitter is that they are much more
likely to be sending the death threat
than to be receiving it
be Far and Away you want to talk about
abuse and hate and all that the most
abusive hateful vicious
group of people on Twitter and in fact
across the entire country are trans
activists not even close
of course they're going to be vicious
and hateful
yeah think about how much they've been
empowered
and these are mostly the mostly men
you know it's mostly men
um identifying as women
who are the most absolutely vicious
because they've been empowered in this
way they've already been empowered to
appropriate the identities of women
um they've already been you know they
they've they've declared that they want
to act out their fetishes in public and
and uh and and in the in the entire
culture has bowed before them
in that regard
already narcissistic going in and so
we've only we've only just pumped uh up
their egos even more and their their
sense of uh entitlement and and all of
that
and that comes through in the way that
they operate on Twitter
all right I gotta I I do need to mention
this because this is the most important
story of the day and you know every day
I'm reminded that I am an old man and
I'm getting older and this is my
reminder for today
CNN has the report Global pop sensation
black pink have been chosen as Time
magazine's 2022 Entertainer of the Year
making the four woman band the second
K-pop artist to earn the title after BTS
in 2020
selected by YG Entertainment a big South
Korean label that screens performers for
Star Quality and trains them intensively
the quartet Jenny jissu Lisa and Rose
found International stardom quickly
after their 2016 debut their first LP
the album sold more than one million
copies in less than a month after 2020
release now I've honestly never heard of
this group they are entertainers of the
Year Global Sensations I've never heard
of them I've been deprived of this
Sensational music I'm pretty upset about
that I got to be honest they named their
first album album so that shows you
these girls are creative Geniuses and
I'd like to learn more about them learn
more about these artists so I thought
that we could together listen to what is
I guess their biggest hit to this point
it's called pink venom so black pink
pink venom they certainly seem to enjoy
the color pink what else do they have to
say
now you're really hoping that we could
listen to some and we are let's listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
wow
extraordinary I mean extraordinary just
extraordinary
listen to these lyrics black pink black
pink black pink black pink kick in the
door waving the Coco I talked that talk
Runway as I walk
one by one then two by two makes no
sense you couldn't get a dollar out of
me
look what you made us do
this that pink venom this that pink
venom
this that pink venom straight to your
Dome like whoa whoa whoa straight to
your Dome like ah
that's poetry that's what that is I mean
this is poetry in our culture it's the
best we can do and maybe that causes you
to fall into Despair and wish you were
never born maybe it makes death by wood
chipper seem almost appealing by
comparison maybe or maybe you're like me
and you listen to the words and you hear
the deeper meaning
like they say they say black pink black
pink black pink black pink what does
that mean it's their group name right so
they are they're announcing themselves
they're boldly announcing proclaiming
their existence their selfhood their
standing staring into the void saying I
am here I exist as a very existential
way to begin the song and then they say
kick in the door waving the Coco what
does that mean
there are multiple interpretations for
every every verse in this case what are
they waving Coco hot cocoa why would
they wave hot cocoa wouldn't that cause
Burns
that's the point how Coco brings Joy you
can also
burn you it's sweet it's hot it's
scalding isn't life like that I mean
isn't is not life itself a battle
between
joy and tragedy
is it a battle or is it a game an
interplay a dance
that's the question that they're asking
I want you to think about one other line
because this is the best they say
straight to your Dome like whoa whoa
whoa
what is straight to your Dome
what is it well it's whoa whoa whoa what
does that mean it's impossible to say
why because in modern culture we're
constantly bombarded by information by
Noise by messages light sound right whoa
whoa whoa it's a lot to take in
all of this is straight to your Dome
my Dome the domes of the world
what do you do with it how do you make
sense of it what's the answer blackpink
doesn't have an answer because life is
not about finding
the answer it's about
inhabiting the moment for all its pain
and joy that it might bring
that's what I took out of that song Just
insightful beautiful playful yet tragic
a masterpiece
they are the entertainers
of the year and deservedly so
all right let's get to the comment
section do you know their name
they're the sweet baby game
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
shop the best Brewing gear thermoses
mugs and apparel designed for folks who
love country and coffee Black Rifle
coffee sources the most exotic roast
from around the globe all coffee is
roasted here in the US by veteran-led
teams of coffee experts you can stuff
your Christmas stockings with the latest
roasts from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Walsh better yet sign your
Secret Santa up for a coffee Club
subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roast when you need the most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee is a veteran founded and
operated company they take pride in
serving coffee and culture to people who
love America every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes go to
blackriflecoffee.com use promo code
Walsh for 10 off coffee Coffee Gear
apparel or when you sign up for a new
coffee Club subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 percent off Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
chadius gigadeus says I guess Tick Tock
having a whole different Limited
educational version for children in
China wasn't a good enough hint for how
detrimental it can be for youth if
unrestricted you really need to spell
things out for people nowadays yeah that
should really be it's like the classic
thing if you go to a restaurant and uh
you you hear that none of the people
working at the restaurant would ever eat
the food
then that should really uh tell you
something and it's the same thing with
Tick Tock they're serving up this this
food they're serving this dish to our
kids here in the west but they would
never eat it themselves so they have a
limited version of tick tock that's that
is as chadius points out
is educational you know it's very toned
down very educational
and yet they ship a totally different
version to our country and to Western
countries and then we as the incredibly
stupid parents say oh yeah sure go ahead
here you go nine-year-old daughter
here's a phone with full unrestricted
internet access I'll go ahead and spend
six hours a day on this app from China
that the Chinese won't even let their
kids use at least not in the form that
I'm giving it to you right now
uh Tommy Wiseau says letting your
children have a tick tock account is
child abuse
yeah I'm I'm uh
I'm I'm there I'm right there with you
you know I I do think and I don't say
that lightly but it is actually abusive
to let your child be on Tick Tock is is
I don't know how else to put it you know
it's
it is going to hurt them it is there's
no chance of it doing anything but
hurting them it can't do anything else
it's not designed to do anything else
it's the only question of how much does
it hurt them
let's see
Shin to skull says some interesting
usernames today Matt I remember that
when I was young in the 80s and 90s
dangerous and stupid stunts and dares
were performed in front of a live group
or crowd but there's a better chance
someone would dissuade a potentially
deadly stunt or if someone was in dire
need during or after a stunt or dare
people were there to step in and help
these kids are alone in their room with
no other voice of reason or uh back up
on hand
scary yeah this is the point I was
trying to point to yesterday and I think
it's a very good point
that we should think more about because
you know if we're talking about the the
blackout game the choking day or
whatever you want to call it and there
were some comments pointing out as I
acknowledged yesterday that
this Tick Tock didn't invent this the
kids today that are doing this choke out
thing are not the first ones to do it
and yeah I can remember
I I never did it myself because just it
never seemed appealing to like being
choked never seemed appealing to me but
I can remember being in middle school
and um this is before social media
and people were doing this thing the
difference is that as you as you point
out it's a very important difference
that yeah kids have always been doing
stupid things participating in Dumb
dares and stunts and everything
especially especially boys
uh but girls as well it's always been
the case
but with social media it becomes a
delivery mechanism for this stuff
it uh it incentivizes doing it it
provides even more incentive but then
also
oftentimes kids are participating in
these dangerous stunts and dares in
isolation
they're recording it so they can post it
online if they survive whatever stupid
thing they're doing
whereas in the past yeah you you know
because you only do this for an audience
that's the only reason kids do this it's
like because it's peer pressure and it's
an audience and they're trying to get
attention attention like kids always
have but in the past if you wanted to
have an audience and you wanted to get
attention and the audience was going to
be in the room with you and so at the
very least if something went
catastrophically wrong you would hope
that there'd be someone there to go get
an adult to call 9-1-1 whatever
now the audience is in Virtual space and
uh and oftentimes you you know you you
put it in front of the audience after
it's done or even if it's being live
streamed they're not physically there
which makes all this all the more
dangerous
finally Joshua says wow LOL I've been
disappointed so many times today I don't
know where to start very sad to hear
these things from you man I knew it
couldn't be true for too long
adios my friend
I don't know what part of the show this
is in reference to
tell me it's Santa Claus tell me it's
what's it it's because I said that I
that my kids believe in Santa Claus
I'm sorry we have to part ways but
please tell me that's the reason
because that's just hilarious j-man says
Matt would be a brutal dictator probably
would have to live exactly like he sees
fit or not at all
now you're getting the point that's the
whole
uh Theocratic fascist dictator deal
the new Jeremy's range of hair skin and
body part products is here and no one
will enjoy gifting it more this
Christmas than me and the sweet baby
gang not just because uh gift bundles
are 30 off right now which is a great
deal but because the new Jeremy's body
wash and facial cleanser are made with
bamboo charcoal
um this is charcoal body wash that's
right the charcoal of bamboo plants
which is a thing I guess the only thing
standing between pandas and their
well-deserved demise is uh is bamboo I
get it so we're gonna chop down all the
bamboo put it in a body wash
and all the pandas finally die as they
deserve this is our sales pitch I guess
this Christmas your family will love
receiving a Jeremy's razors gift bundle
what's not to love about tea tree and
peppermint shampoo and conditioner
oatmeal and citrus body soap but don't
forget bamboo charcoal every morning as
your family enjoys the freshness of an
aloe vera infused cleanser you'll have
the satisfaction of knowing that they're
starving the world's remaining pandas to
death and they're all going to die not
just die but die agonizing slow deaths
it's getting pretty dark give yourself
the gift of giving Jeremy's 100 woke
free products and get 30 off gift
bundles before December 15th to arrive
in time for Christmas just go to
dailywire.com Walsh and kill all the
pandas now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
since Meghan Markle and Prince Harry
dramatically announced that they were
stepping down from their roles in the
royal family and moving to America
they said that they um valued their
privacy and could no longer tolerate
living under the white hot glare of the
spotlight their stated reasoning may
have been
you know convincing to you at the time
if you were dumb enough to believe that
Meghan Markle was the sort of girl who
marries into royalty because she values
her privacy but if you're at least
intelligent enough to score higher than
an earthworm on an IQ test then you knew
that Harry and Megan were seeking
attention not shirking from it
and if you're in this latter category
the smarter than earthworm demographic
you you have not then been surprised to
find that this private and humble extra
royal couple has spent the last couple
of years
seeking attention wherever they can find
it they've done multiple tell-all
interviews one conducted by Oprah
they've signed book deals they've signed
multi-million dollar podcast deals Megan
has posed for literally every magazine
cover in existence outside of maybe Car
Driver magazine although maybe she got
around to that too they have sought a
very peculiar form of privacy indeed
a form that involves appearing on every
sort of medium willfully attracting
attention and then monetizing that
attention this is the kind of private
life they wish to lead and now they're
going to continue their privacy Tour by
starring in a Netflix docu-series which
premieres this weekend and here's the
trailer
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Music]
all around the world she's becoming a
royal rock star
and then
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
how many times are they going to milk
this exact same no one has heard this
before no one knows the full truth we
we've we've heard you tell the supposed
full truth about 46 times in the last
year
so I believe the official title of this
is uh give me attention the movie either
that or they're just calling it Harry
and Megan which is the same idea either
way of course everything that Meghan
Markle is involved in starting with her
marriage is at its core a publicity
stunt and a sham and this is film is no
different in fact eagle-eyed viewers
have noticed that between the two main
trailers released for the series
at least three of the images in these
trailers of media harassing and hounding
the couple are taken out of context
from events where neither Harry nor
Megan were even present
bbc.com has this report a photograph of
Paparazzi appears in for in the first
trailer just before a clip of Harry
saying he had to do everything that he
could to protect his family
however it is said to have actually been
taken at a Harry Potter Premiere five
years before the Duke and Duchess even
met a clip in the second trailer which
apparently illustrates Paparazzi
hounding the couple was actually taken
when former model Katie Price arrived at
Crawley magistrates Court last December
shortly before that shot the Duke of
Sussex is heard speaking of the pain and
suffering of women marrying into the
royal family adding that he did not want
history to repeat itself as Eclipse
shows men apparently chasing someone
with cameras the clip was in fact
recorded as price arrived to be
sentenced over a drunk driving charge
one section of the second trailer also
features clips of reporters
photographers and cameramen apparently
in close pursuit of the couple however
one media Crush seen by viewers was not
targeting the royal family right the
royal couple but rather president Donald
Trump's former loyal lawyer Michael
Cohen leaving his New York apartment in
2019 to serve time in prison for
financial crimes campaign Finance
violations and lying to Congress
so it's pretty hilarious that they
crammed three misleading images just
into the trailer who knows how many lies
they'll be able to pack into the full
series
it's also grotesque but that's par for
the course with Harry and Megan
these two may have ostensibly stepped
down from the Royal occupation but only
to exchange one throne and one crown for
another because they are now king and
queen victim
and it is a symbolic figurehead type
position just like the one they left
but it also carries a considerable
amount of power in our culture not to
mention profit potential
they are in many ways
the perfect representation of victimhood
in modern Western culture
this is the service they're providing us
is by is by showing us what victimhood
really entails these days they are our
victimhood mascots
immensely privileged
absurdly wealthy living lives of
unimaginable Comfort surrounded by
ostentatious luxury
they're celebrated by the media they're
fond over they're applauded
yet they can't stop whining they are
never happy none of their riches no
amount of public adulation will convince
these spoiled self-centered brats that
they're anything but oppressed
and downtrodden
and what's more this is another Hallmark
of modern victimhood they maintain their
victimhood delusions even as they
viciously attack the ones they claim to
be helplessly victimized by
so Harry has turned on his own family
aired their dirty laundry monetized its
airing
and yet still pretends to be somehow the
injured party
now are there tears fake
is it all an act
well yes and no yes in the sense that
Meghan Markle is a sociopath who has
probably never experienced a fully
authentic human emotion in her life but
know in the sense that you know to the
extent that they can feel emotions at
all they are actually upset I believe
that part
because part of the curse of being a
narcissist
is that you're never satisfied no matter
how much attention you get It's never
enough
so long as you remain still standing on
a planet that revolves around the Sun
rather than around you so so long as
there are people out there living lives
that have nothing to do with you and
talking about things other than you and
prioritizing their own well-being over
yours
so long as any of that remains the case
you will feel persecuted
because narcissism is insatiable
there are no happy narcissists no
content narcissists
whatever they have they should always
have more in their minds whatever anyone
else does or says they should have
always done or said something different
they're always being attacked they're
always being conspired against everyone
is Whispering about them behind their
backs they think
narcissism and victimhood go hand in
hand our culture of victimhood is really
then a culture of narcissism
and Harry and Megan are
it's perfect Representatives
and Creations
and for that they are today
canceled and that'll do it for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not we'll talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]